[Music]
dr. strange your work saved the lives of
thousands what if I told you that
reality is one of many strange is
incredibly arrogant brilliant sort of
extraordinary and his need to control
faints to control destiny and in
particular death has brought sin to the
height of his profession as a
neurosurgeon he has a car crash and he
loses the use of his hands and she
spends all his money having operations
to have his hands put back together and
they don't work he has quite a journey
as his life starts to fall apart
deep spends what his lost pennies on a
ticket and goes to the poor
he's searching for a cure for his hands
and the issues that he's having my
character introduces him to this
different brain mystical world he finds
the ancient one who is the sorcerer
supreme you wonder what I see in your
future possibility
brings out this spiritual dimension
which he never knew was possible and he
soon realizes the potential is someone
who could help on a grander scale that
he'd ever imagined actually existed
we're excited about the villains in this
film these are people who become seduced
by what they find on the other side the
guys up close well they are interested
in spilling the barriers between these
dimensions which would annihilate our
entire universe Davis who is no other
way was a lot of real-world live action
in this film there's a lot of drama a
lot of comedy but there's also the most
extraordinary fantastical adventure but
he's gonna be a great cinematic Rider
[Music]
no it's one of many this doesn't make
any sense
not everything does
[Music]